i don't even know where to begin because
let's do this let's talk about this
this this doj anti-trust suit so i've
got this story right here from
fox lawmakers hail doj antitrust lawsuit
against google is long overdue
senator hawley called it the most
important anti-trust case in a
generation
today's lawsuit is the most important in
generation senator josh hawley said
google and its fellow big tech
monopolists exercise unprecedented power
of the lives of ordinary
ordinary americans controlling
everything from the news we read
does it to the security of our most
personal information
and google in particular has gathered
and maintained that power through
illegal means
the doj suit alleges that google has
used its dominance in online search and
advertising
to stifle competition and boost profits
the suit could be
an opening shot in a battle against a
number of big tech companies
in coming months a google spokesperson
told fox news
today's lawsuit by the department of
justice is deeply flawed people use
google because they choose to not
because they're forced to
or because they can't find alternatives
we have a fuller statement this morning
later the tech giant released a lengthy
blog post in which it said the doj
complaint relies on dubious antitrust
arguments
this lawsuit would do nothing to help
consumers to the contrary it would
artificially prop up lower quality
search alternatives
raise phone prices and make it harder
for people to get the search services
they want to use
the lawsuit says for years google has
entered into exclusionary agreements
including tying arrangements and engaged
in anti-competitive conduct to lock up
distribution channels
and block rivals american consumers are
forced to accept google's policies
privacy practices and use of personal
data and new companies with innovative
business models
cannot emerge from google's long shadow
for the sake of american consumers
advertisers and all companies now
reliant on the internet economy
the time has come to stop google's
anti-competitive conduct and restore
competition
it says i think that was a whole lot of
hot air and
it is the wrong target and it's going to
miss because i think google makes a
really good point
i don't use bing i don't want to use
bing i do use go sometimes
you know so there are choices when it
comes to search
the issue with google is they're more
than just a search engine and the doj
lawsuit is very much focused on search
and how they manipulate search
no the issue is that youtube for
instance which we're on
is heavily subsidized by other areas of
google
because of that no other video platform
can compete and some argue
no video platform could survive with how
expensive it is to do streaming to do
this i mean i'll tell you guys
we're doing this show right now cost me
nothing to press
live on this stream so that all of you
can watch nothing
google just says if we make money off it
we'll take a cut so that can exist on a
lot of other platforms it's really
expensive like podcasting for instance
if i got anywhere near the amount of
views on podcasting it would be an
insane amount of money
to handle all that bandwidth so anyway
let's uh
let's let's dive into it what do you
think alan you were telling me before
you don't think this anti-trust i was
going to do anything
well it's important and it's good that
the republicans are punishing google and
being seen to pub
to punish google because i think the
idea that a lot of tech companies have
had for a long time is we don't have to
listen to the warnings of republicans
about censorship because they're not
they're never going to regulate it so
they're never going to do anything
so there's one positive thing to it also
positive the fact that we might actually
get to see behind the curtain see
how google is training its search
algorithm that's something we don't know
about really we've got
some idea of it based on whistleblowers
i've talked to based on
james o'keefe's whistleblowers as well
but uh if
through the case we can get a look at
that that would be excellent
but i don't think antitrust focuses on
the right
thing so it's true that google is a
monopoly that controls 90 of search
worldwide uh it's true that they're you
know pretty bad to competitors not just
uh search competitors but as you said
you know
competing video platforms uh competing
uh email right reviewing as well yeah
uh so it'll be very good for companies
like yelp but
it doesn't really focus on i think the
real problem of google which is its
vast power over political information
its ability to swing elections
and its ability to destroy people's
livelihoods like if you're our website
if you run a website and it goes from
page one of google to page
a thousand it's gonna have a huge impact
on your business you're done
yeah i knew a guy who did online sales
and google one
day changed the algorithm and then his
company didn't exist anymore
yeah well look look at what they've done
in news publishers so uh breitbart news
published a couple of months ago
research showing they've cut
visibility on breitbart links by 99
uh compared to 2016. there aren't a lot
of other websites as well
uh almost every conservative news
website with the exception of one or two
like fox
just colossal fall invisibility since
2016. and that's that's completely
artificial because traffic numbers
haven't gone down it's just google
visibility that's gone
right my my two main channels are
blacklisted on google you can't search
for them they're gone
so maybe uh maybe i'll reap some
benefits from an anti-trust thing where
they you know separate all these
companies or whatever i don't know
but i kind of i kind of feel like i
think you know andrew yang made this
point he was like
nobody wants to use bing antitrust isn't
the real isn't the real issue
i guess kind of like what you're saying
but then when you have google
alphabet i suppose now controlling all
of these different industries in one big
massive corporation maybe the issue
isn't searched maybe the issue is search
needs to be separate from video needs to
be separate from
email needs to be separate from g you
know google drive and all that stuff
if you really want competition among the
search engines to give you know smaller
players like dr gohan advantage one of
the things one of my google sources told
me
is that what you need to do is separate
the data from the rest of google
and say the data is going to be
available anonymized to competitors
because that's what that's what gives
google its advantage you
take them away from the data you make
the data non-exclusive
and suddenly other search engines don't
compete i have a i have a friend who's
doing this big push for
owning your own data it's like a big
movement and if that were the case then
that would that could function it could
function that way so if if
every every bit of information that one
of these companies might get from you
you own and can distribute freely as you
choose
that's a really interesting idea because
then all these other companies can build
better services
based off of all of this all this data
anonymized it's the basis of their
market power it's also the basis of
their ability to politically
manipulate people which we can get into
actually you know i guess i guess in
that regard i would say their search is
a monopoly
because they've created the system where
they they
it's an interesting phenomenon we're
seeing with social media twitter
facebook and google where
the only reason they're a monopoly they
dominate these spaces because no one
uses anything else
and because no one uses anything else
there can be no competition
so it's it it is challenging i can't
blame twitter because everybody's on
twitter
but because everybody's on twitter no
one uses anything else it's creating
monopolistic problems
right there's an argument that these are
natural monopolies because you
you want to go to a social network that
has the most amount of people
on it that's where you'll get maximum
viewership for your content
um and with search uh the advantage gets
locked in once you have that amount of
data because once you have it
your competitors by definition don't
have it uh and google's really mastered
this this is why they've
gone into smartphones they've gone into
browsers they've gone into
uh laptops because that's just more ways
to gather data
yeah this makes me think so i think
giving the data to the user is paramount
i agree with you guys but
i also think you have to free their
software code because if it's private
code
and they give you data it could be false
data and you wouldn't know
so the only way to verify that the data
is real is if you understand what the
code
is measuring i don't necessarily agree i
mean that would be that would be them
defrauding you yes and defrauding the
government yeah i would be and
i i just think if they commit a crime
you should punish them for the people
you wouldn't know they were committing a
crime well
the government would subpoena them to
verify the records by showing their code
yeah but they have to release the code
well i mean the government is public
right the idea is they can look at the
code without
revealing trade secrets and so they can
see if the data is verified or not
i don't think just the company giving up
the property they develop makes sense
i don't know what do you think well
there needs to be a lot more
transparency what i would like to see uh
especially with regards to political
manipulation
is how do they train their so-called
hate speech algorithms
and their disinformation algorithms so
when you're training an algorithm
the way you do it is you're training it
to recognize language if you're trying
to detect certain types of speech
and you'd have to train it on a set of
data this is hate speech this isn't hate
speech that's what you're giving the
algorithm
so i would love to see their list of
examples that they've used to train
these algorithms
that would be the way that would be like
the smoking well we've had so many i've
smoking guns already it's kind of
ridiculous to say but that would be yes
yet another smoking gun that would
conclusively prove political bias
although again i say that the the
black-pilled reality is that we've had
the smoking guns
and nothing has been done about it
there's like a pile of guns in the other
room that are a flame
it's like it's like they're sending
smoke signals with the burning guns like
wow look at all that smoke coming out we
know it
and then you've got there's a reason why
it's republicans going after
these companies and not democrats the
dem i mean and the democrats are stupid
for it
don't get me wrong but they're sitting
there and they're just like well we're
not getting banned so let's roll with it
they're banning our opponents
but what it's really doing is creating
this warped reality where conservatives
look normal
and the left looks psychotic like you
get you get antifa on twitter saying
we're gonna go burn it down and a
regular person's like that's crazy
but the conservatives anything kind of
like that are nuked instantly you see
what i mean uh well i'll make two points
about that first of all the republican
establishment especially
the ones in the senate are complete
worses many of them bought and paid for
by google
so we saw the new york post get censored
last week
and senate republicans came out oh we're
going to subpoena jack dorsey
uh i think it was a day ago and they
voted it down or whatever yeah
the republican republicans wavered we're
not going to subpoena jack dorsey
so i'm being maybe too hushed there are
some senators who are very good in the
issue hawley cruz blackburn
but uh like the vast majority of
republican senators they can't be
trusted on this issue either
uh but i will say that the second point
the left supporting censorship this is
extremely naive if you think
these technologies that have been
developed by silicon valley won't one
day be turned against the left
the anti-war left especially yep you're
being very
they're already getting nuked already
yeah yeah so i remember when veritas did
that expose on pinterest
uh something they didn't catch when they
were talking about live action being
censored the pro-life organization
i i looked at and i was like whoa
anti-media is on there and they're like
you know anti-police brutality anti-war
progressive left anti-establishment
they're getting censored why would an
anti-war leftist organization be
censored
isn't that weird i think it's because
it's not so much about
the conservatives when they're doing
censorship it's about the people who
oppose the establishment
and when like like you said in your book
they're trying to you know what are they
doing they're trying they're
stopping the the trump movement yeah the
trump movement is anti-establishment
trump booted out the the crony rhinos
and took over the republican party so
what's really happening is a censorship
is against those who dare challenge the
establishment and that includes anti-war
left
and that includes for for the most part
the larger group the conservatives those
who supported trump
so most of the book is uh based on stuff
from silicon valley sources
but by the way if you want to get it
it's called deleted and you can find it
deletedbook.com
but uh there's one source i talked to
from the government and he's been
following this censorship issue for a
long time
and uh the way he put it i think was
very chilling he said
up until 2015 2016 western establishment
elites
saw internet free speech as a good thing
because it helped them regime
change and destabilize countries abroad
that was you know twitter the arab
spring
eastern europe as well color revolutions
but he said
as soon as you had brexit as soon as you
had donald trump establishment elites
realized
oh no this technology can be used to
regime change us
that's the mentality now you know i love
uh during the the arab spring i had a
bunch of friends who were active
activists who are trying to provide
communications and then one day my
friend was like
let's notice something you notice all
these libyan revolutionary people
speak perfect colloquial english and i
started laughing i was like that's an
interesting thing right and they're like
that's really weird
and then they try and justify it saying
well it makes sense because
twitter is a very western thing so only
people educated in the west or who are
western would be using it
and some other people were like i don't
know maybe maybe they're just trying to
convince people who use the platform in
america
that libyans want us to intervene and
then we did and hillary clinton said we
came we saw he died
i'm not insinuating anything i'm just
saying what people were talking about
the time i don't know
but it is it is uh do you know do you
know about um
barrett brown's investigation project pm
uh no enlightenment
this is a long time ago he ended up
going i i think i could be getting the
details from i think he went to prison
partly because of it because they were
doing uh uh
they were reviewing stratfor data so
this is strategic forensics it's it's i
guess it's like oh i do remember
the big structural thing yeah yeah yeah
yeah i do remember this and so in it we
learned that
i think the us air force was purchasing
sock puppet accounts these are
a sock puppet account is a dummy it's a
bot it's what they
they say bots it's an account with a
fake picture and a fake name
and then one person controls 50 of them
they're called sock puppets
to create the perception of popular
opinion this is one of the biggest
problems that's affecting big
corporations today
like pepsi will put out a commercial and
it's like it's like a guy drinking you
know and throwing a football
and they'll get inundated with like 50
to 100 messages on twitter saying you're
racist
and then all of a sudden they're like
we're being attacked what do we do quick
issue an apology and it's like dude it's
one guy with 50 accounts
so we learned this back in 2011 i think
it was 2012
that u.s military was uh was was buying
stock puppet accounts for what purpose
middle eastern intelligence operations
and persuasion
psychological operations and things like
that so this has been
an ongoing thing and at some point
you had these the political parties
realize they can do it i gotta be honest
i think the democrats figured it out way
before the republicans
oh no doubt yeah definitely they were
using facebook stuff first
i mean act blue which you're familiar
with act blue is the progressive
you know fundraising it's a progressive
gofundme essentially
and then republicans only launched win
red recently and that's the you know the
republican version of it so the
democrats have had
have had uh uh you know have been on the
forefront of this
but something weird happened in in in
the trump era like in the 2015 with
with the the the trump army of the trump
train the meme smiths
all of a sudden you had an organic
explosion of people who are actively
producing content and propping up trump
something that they couldn't pay for you
know yeah and that and
you hit the nail on the head this is
stuff the obama campaign was doing in
2012 cambridge analytica
was just a smaller scale version of what
obama was doing in 2012
with facebook's help and it was an obama
campaign
uh pretty senior obama campaign person
who revealed that he was working
directly on it
she said um that facebook actually
helped them
uh and you know gave them gave them like
assistance in 2012.
uh her name was carol something i'm
blanking on her last name carol peterson
perhaps
um but also with the bots the uh the
bots he mentioned from stratfor
or sacrifice the reason there was this
panic after trump's win was because uh
all of these people the foreign policy
assembly have been doing this for years
they uh they started accusing everyone
else of you know
using bots and stock profits and
disinformation of course they were
terrified that uh that would happen to
them because they'd be doing it for so
long so they couldn't imagine that this
movement might actually
be organic might actually be real people
they thought it was just the same thing
they'd been doing for years and years
but then they started pushing that fake
russia narrative
claiming that it was russia doing all
this it it just wasn't
it probably was like a kid in russia in
an apartment and they traced some ip
and they got like one and they were like
oh the russians the russians it's the
government the russian government
well actually it was just some dude who
maybe had a russian ip
well the story now i guess is that it's
just such a weird
and complicated conspiracy of nonsense
that's uh who was it was it was it uh uh
was it ratcliffe who issued this
statement basically saying that
hillary clinton created the russian
intelligence
was believed that hillary clinton was
going to create a fake campaign accusing
trump of working with them
to get the public uh uh to get the press
cycle off of her email story
and that obama was briefed on this so
they knew
at least the insinuation is hillary
clinton created the fake idea just out
of the blue it seemed like it it came
right after her email scandal and she
just started saying it she's like
trump's working with russia and it's
like uh-huh
it was so happy for this thing yeah and
you know who had convinced
it convinced well maybe they were in it
i don't know but all these
well-funded foreign policy ngos
that are european ngos american ngos
uh just a few days ago we published a
story at breitbart news about the german
marshall fund
this is one of these extremely
well-funded foreign policy ngos very
focused on russia very focused on the
balkans
they're the ones have been pushing the
disinformation narrative the russian
disinformation narrative
for four years now and pressuring the
tech companies to
censor what they call disinformation
another one of those groups the atlantic
council
are working directly with facebook and
this other one the german marshall fund
they've actually uh
said that breitbart news fox news the
blaze basically every conservative news
website needs to be uh suppressed by
facebook they need to apply friction
because in the words of this think tank
which by the way is founded by the us
government
and foreign governments and the german
government sounds like foreign
interference to me i don't know
uh how that word is defined these days
but they said uh facebook has to apply
friction which is their word for uh
suppression of all these uh so-called
deceptive news sites thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you